no tv show is perfect but liv and maddie
comes pretty close
despite all the great moments there are
a few mistakes you might notice on your
first or
tenth watch through just be warned that
after you notice these bloopers
you will not be able to unsee them why
would you purposefully turn into
oncoming traffic when you can go up one
block and make three rights
the pilot episode set the scene for the
entire series
as we saw liv arrive home after spending
time in hollywood but it seems like the
team messed up one important detail
which twin is older you stole my face
this scene clearly implies maddie was
born first
yet later on in sweet 16 or rooney it's
established that liv is the older twin
and her birthday is technically a day
ahead of her sisters
don't feel bad though i am a day older
according to this episode
liv was born at 11 56 p.m on the fifth
while maddie was born at 1202 on the 6th
which contradicts matty's statement that
she had their face first
wait so maddie's never celebrated on her
actual birthday
there's no denying that liv is the
hostess with the mostest in new year's
eva rooney when she performs at a
rocking new year's eve party but things
get a little bit out of control when she
shows off her latest product endorsement
the drive by liv is the most powerful
hair dryer in the world
this poor clown learns the power of the
drive by liv all too well as it sends
him
hurtling backwards and tosses his wig
off his head but wait
the clown was clearly wearing a red wig
in previous shots of the party
yet when he puts his wig back on it's
multi-colored
is that a color-changing hairdryer
would you like a new one sleeper rooney
introduced us to parker's friend evan
who's possibly the best house guest out
there
but he gets to let loose a little bit
and take part in a dart fight with
parker and his fellow sleepover
attendees
when the boys are done there are darts
everywhere including stuck to his green
blanket flung over the back of a chair
and scattered on the floor
when liv interrupts the fun to show off
her dinosaur impression evan thinks that
she's choking and stands up to help
evan honey i'm not choking but when he
sits back down the darts on the blanket
and some of the ones on the floor
have mysteriously vanished
dude even my mom would think this was
lame
those darts are far from the only
appearing or disappearing objects found
in the rooney household
in one scene splat tries to put his feet
up on a coffee table
and accidentally knocks over a bowl of
popcorn sending the kernels flying all
over the place
you can clearly see that the bowl is
empty yet just a moment later
it's almost full again despite the
popcorn still scattered all over the
table
youtube bobbleheads have to clean our
room today
liv couldn't resist showing off her
tristan lycanth costume in slumper
rooney which was all fun and games until
she couldn't remove
her prosthetic teeth or ears when johnny
nimbus refused to heed her request to
reschedule the segment nibbling with
nimbus she decided to cleverly
camouflage her predicament with some
strategic accessorizing
smart johnny nimbus might be a better
cook than we thought because check out
the red pan on the stove
well i got a griddle full of bratz and a
side order of get to know you
in an instant it's filled with eggs
despite the fact that it was empty
moments earlier
who's going to tell him that you're not
supposed to put eggs on a frying pan
without removing their shells first
the the armor glue says permanent
in shuarooni parker convinces evan to
act
like a less than perfect house guest
rather than have him set high
expectations for karen when it comes to
their behavior
when she relegates them to playing with
a box of crayons with
the sharpener removed of course keep a
close eye on the box
no not because it includes burnt sienna
but rather because it can't stay in one
place
we see it in an upright position and
then all of a sudden it's lying on its
side despite the fact that neither boy
touched it so
if i don't ever do anything i don't ever
get to do anything
here we have another error associated
with liv's role as tristan lycanth
she and maddie switch places so liv can
take her sister's driving test
and we'll talk about how that went a
little bit later as for maddie she
managed to win over some reluctant fans
when posing as
live but is that as impressive as this
employee's ability to teleport you can
see a woman with brown hair and glasses
standing by the door in a yellow shirt
then all of a sudden she's directly
behind parker
and if you blink she vanishes from that
spot too
all hail the sea tristan
[Applause]
in the pilot episode of liv and maddie
the two twins have a huge fight after
liv
asks diggy out while pretending to be
maddie of course they end up reconciling
but
during this emotional scene we couldn't
help but notice liv's bracelet
it keeps disappearing and then
reappearing off her right wrist while
she talks to maddie
liv decided to stay at home with her
family but apparently
some of her jewelry had other ideas you
couldn't drag me away
how many of us have dreamed of having a
twin we could switch places with
well liv and maddie fans know that those
kinds of hijinks can go terribly wrong
let's go back to liv taking maddie's
driver's test because it turns out the
instructor wearing a helmet wasn't the
worst idea
liv crashes the car into a garbage can
which leaves debris lingering on the
hood of the car
the rappers are still there after she
strikes the mailbox and the car comes to
a stop
yet after the airbags deflate the hood
is totally clean
only one of us passed total bummering
in the first episode of liv and maddie
the family airs their grievances and we
can see pete holding a stopwatch but
don't stop watching it
because after liv blows the air horn for
a second time
pete drops the hand holding it down yet
an instant later
it's raised back up then parker
complains about not being able to use
the bathroom with the door open
despite the fact that his family has
changed his diapers before
all of a sudden the stopwatch vanishes
out of pete's hand entirely
then when liv says she might as well go
back you can see
pete grasp the air horn with his left
hand that was
holding the stopwatch before quickly
correcting himself
and putting it on his other hand well
guess what my life doesn't need fixing
seriously how could parker bringing home
tarantulas
not go horribly wrong he claims to have
six of the creepy crawlies
and promptly loses all but one of them
he and joey try to hunt them down
and immediately find one crawling on the
table alright
caught one they later find one crawling
on an unfortunate slumber party guests
and managed to grab that one
too though a little bit too late now the
boys have a total of three tarantulas
meaning there should be three remaining
when we see five of them clinging to
karen's sweater
these spiders aren't exactly native to
wisconsin so where did the two other
ones come from
i know this is completely in my head but
i feel like i can feel them crawling all
over me
on pete's birthday he wants negative
five presents which means he wants to
get rid of five things around the house
which his wife karen is not crazy about
one of his picks is an artichoke candle
holder which karen bought for parker
after he agreed to try
artichokes for the first time karen said
it was like she could still feel it
there after they placed it in the box to
get rid of and it's possible this was a
bit of foreshadowing since this wasn't
really the end of it we saw it in its
place on the end table in the episode's
grandma aruni
and video aruni did you see it in any
others let us know down below
no 20 bucks what's going on
who could forget the time-honored
tradition of cowbell week
this special time of year involves kids
putting cowbells on each other while
trying to avoid receiving one themselves
there are actually two mistakes in this
episode and the first happens when
willow targets mackenzie with a cowbell
she calls out mckenzie's dress despite
the fact that her classmate is
clearly wearing a skirt and top was this
a last minute wardrobe change or a
simple script mistake i love your dress
at the end of cowbell week maddie is the
victor and she isn't exactly humble
about her victory
when she's taunting her classmates about
their losses she says
but maddie didn't bell this girl in her
sleep because we saw her
do it while she was wide awake at school
in the beginning of the episode
maybe all of maddie's victories started
to blur together after a while
well that sounds like loser talk
both liv and maddie are portrayed by the
talented dove cameron who switches up
her style to make each character stand
out in the first two seasons
liv has a side part in her hair which
helps distinguish her from maddie
yet in the third season she also started
wearing her hair parted down the middle
which isn't a mistake on its own
but it was when it happened in continue
to rooney this episode was meant to take
place
immediately after champa rooney in which
liv's hair was parted on the side
her abrupt middle part was a continuity
error that some fans couldn't help but
notice
this is a life-changing offer for me
since dove cameron plays two characters
sometimes the special camera work is
required
and sometimes it goes wrong in this
scene liv and maddie are standing next
to each other when suddenly the sight of
liv's green purse is cut off in an
unnatural way this must have happened
when maddie was added into the scene
later on
i love wearing boots the rest of that
sounds really awful
the kids tease karen for being less than
tech savvy when she treats herself to
the latest smartphone
yep just holding it makes me feel smart
she uses an app called face gab to call
liv
but when parker notices that she has the
hip hop gnome snow cone maker
liv abruptly ends the call by pressing
the speaker button
instead of the obvious disconnect button
on the screen
how did they not tell us we're moving
when maddie plays pin the tail on the
donkey she wears a scarf tied around her
face
then all of a sudden her makeshift
blindfold is off her head
and into her hands despite the fact that
we didn't see her remove it how'd she
take it off and straighten her hair up
so quickly
how are you doing on the whole breakup
thing still hurting but
liv and maddie are twins but they have
differences between them
maddie needs her glasses to see and she
doesn't share her sister's talent for
singing at least
not in the episode switcher rooney yet
in the same season
maddy sings along when liv performs
count me in maybe maddie was just
melting along to the backup vocals of
the track thank you all so much
for coming to the season 4 dvd signing
of singing loud
when matty and josh break up joey
doesn't appreciate having to compete
with her for his friend's attention
when maddie joins them for lunch she
expresses surprise that she has such a
nice time playing with churros and
spending time with her ex
who says you can't be friends with your
ex well clearly
maddie doesn't say that because at this
point she and diggy have broken up and
stayed in contact afterwards
so why was maddie so surprised that she
could be around josh
after they ended things dude
seriously did we miss any liv and maddie
mistakes that you managed to spot
if so share them with us and your fellow
fans in the comments section below and
hey
make sure to hit subscribe to get new
videos from us here at the things
thanks for watching we'll see you again
next time